so just imagine this entire parking lot
pretty much filled with one mirror for a
giant telescope a telescope that will be
the biggest telescope on earth
yeah so it's a it's a it's a little bit
of a fudge because
it's not a symbol that actually gets
used that much it's a circle with a line
through it it's actually more of an
engineering symbol than a physicist
symbol generally speaking in astronomy
bigger is better when it comes to
diameter
all a telescope is is a big light bucket
we just sit out there with a mirror
and collect photons as they come in from
astronomical objects let's take the
story back to the beginning and again as
with most things in astronomy it goes
back to galileo
galileo's first observations with a
telescope he was using a refracting
telescope so a telescope with lenses in
it and the lenses were a few inches
across but basically with optical
telescopes we don't talk about lenses
anymore we talk about mirrors mostly and
the nice thing about mirrors is you can
make them a lot bigger than you can make
lenses so you can build bigger and
bigger telescopes the first telescope
that i ever had some involvement with
was when i was a summer student in
victoria in canada
and that was at the dominion
astrophysical observatory and they have
a lovely telescope there and it's 1.8
meters in diameter
now at the time it was built back in
around 1918 i believe it was for a short
period of time the largest telescope on
earth it was temperamental there
actually was an official stick next to
it with which you had to hit some of the
equipment to make it work and so then we
graduate up into what we might think of
as medium-sized telescopes and these are
telescopes that are maybe
the mirror is maybe four meters in
diameter
so those include telescopes that i've
been to
include the canada france hawaii
telescope in hawaii so of another very
nice summer experience working at that
telescope and something like the william
herschel telescope which is a british
telescope in la palma again a very nice
holiday destination you probably see a
theme
coming in here we tend to build
telescopes where the weather is is good
some of the life of an astronomer is
fairly hard so when you go to hawaii you
may think of beaches and palm trees the
telescopes in hawaii are on top of the
mountain mauna kea they're at 14 000
feet
you're oxygen deprived it looks like the
surface of mars you're above the clouds
you're jet lagged and you're working at
night
so yes you do get to go to the beach at
the end of your observing run
but that's probably after five or six
nights of very very very hard work
well a hubble is kind of the
anomaly here because i said in most
cases bigger is better but the hubble
mirror is only 2.5 meters in diameter
so what's so special about the hubble
well first of all it's in space
so it's not sitting at the bottom of
this really murky moving atmosphere but
not only uh the size of the mirror
matters but the quality of the mirror
and the mirror on hubble was ground to a
precision that i don't think has been
equaled it was incredibly incredibly
precise
of course that's a whole other story
because it was precise in the wrong way
and had to be fixed
thanks to
an accident in the measuring
but it was accurate to i think one
fiftieth of a human hair
so with the hubble it might not be the
biggest telescope on the block but it's
certainly got some of the sharpest
eyesight
yeah so then the next class of
telescopes are something around the six
to eight to ten meter in diameter for
their mirror
so i've used the magellan telescope
in chile so i visited there and stood
underneath that mirror which measures
6.5 meters in diameter which is pretty
big
but we also have lots of telescopes
around the world that have eight meter
mirrors and that's kind of the limit if
you want to build a single lens or a
single mirror you can build a mirror
eight meters across but that's really
pushing the technology because you've
got to build a mirror eight meters
across which is uh optically perfect so
it can actually focus the light so it
has to be figured to within a fraction
of a wavelength of light and it's eight
meters across so from an engineering
point of view it's really pushing the
limits for example if you take a mirror
like that and then you point it in a
different direction which of course is
one of the things you want to do with
the telescope the mirror sags and so you
actually need to have the whole thing
actively controlled with little
pressure pads behind to push it back
into shape so you've got all this sort
of active stuff going on holding it into
shape
so even today the biggest telescopes
which are sort of 10 11 12 meters in
diameter aren't single mirrors we've
gone to this system where you use a
whole series of little segments so you
have lots of hexagonal segments that all
kind of join together like a honeycomb
we have
the amusingly named vlt which is the
very large telescope which is actually
four eight meter telescopes in chile we
the next telescopes the really big ones
are going to be a lot lot bigger than
that
so the one of the first ones that was
bandied about was the the owl the
overwhelmingly large telescope and that
was that was proposed to be a hundred
meters in diameter um so for various
reasons that's probably not going to to
come about so we've downgraded slightly
to instead of the overwhelmingly large
telescope the extremely large telescope
i'm afraid we sort of gave up giving
things exciting names some time ago
it'll probably end up with a more
interesting name when it actually gets
built but for the moment that's what
it's known as
and that's going to have a mirror that
will be 42 meters in diameter so it's a
whole series of more than a thousand
individual segments that are all going
to be joined together to make a single
mirror effectively that's 42 meters in
diameter which as you might imagine is
going to collect an absolute shed load
of light so we're going to be seeing
able to see things which we stand no
chance at all of seeing at the moment
we'll be able to see planets like the
earth orbiting around other nearby stars
and even be able to study the
atmospheres of those planets to figure
out whether there's life on them we'll
be able to see stars in other galaxies
where at the moment we can just see kind
of the fuzzy blur of light we're going
to be able to see galaxies on the other
side of the universe on the kind of
accuracy where currently we can only see
nearby galaxies so it's going to
completely revolutionize astronomy
42 meters 42 meters should we should we
try and get an idea how big that is what
are you going to do what are you gonna
do um so one easy measurement i have is
the computer that goes on my bike so
we're going to go outside and i'm going
to get on my bike and see if we can
measure approximately 42 meters
somewhere in the parking lot and that's
the sad thing these poor photons of
light they've been traveling across the
gulf of space for you know 10 billion
years
hoping some astronomers going to catch
them and they you know they run splat
into the roof of your house and that's
it it's all over so we'll catch some of
them i mean even with a mirror 42 meters
in diameter we're still not going to
catch very many of them but it's a much
bigger bucket than we've had in the past
so we're going to collect a lot more
light than we ever have before okay so
i've got my measuring instrument here
which is my bike and i have a little
wireless bike computer so that just sits
on here so i'm going to reset that now
and we're going to try to see if we can
figure out just how big 42 meters
actually is where they're going to put
this bad boy
that's still it's an interesting
question because obviously there are
kind of astronomical reasons as to why
you might want to put in particular
places for example there's some things
you can only see from the southern
hemisphere there's some things you can
only see from the northern hemisphere so
that's one issue
um you want to put it somewhere dark
because you want to you know you don't
want light pollution to mess up your
images but equally actually these things
consume rather a large amount of power
so at their peak they can use as much
power as a small town so you need
somewhere where there's kind of the
infrastructure you can get electricity
to them you have road access and all
that kind of stuff so you can't really
pick somewhere that's absolutely in the
middle of nowhere
and finally there's politics you know
you've got to put it somewhere that's
politically stable you probably don't
want to put it somewhere where there's
going to be a revolution someone's going
to nationalize your telescope 10 minutes
after you've built it
and even you know if you're trying to
get money out of someone it's usually
easier to get money if you say and i'm
going to build it in your country so
there's lots and lots of things and it's
still i think it will be finalized for
the eelt sometime later this year but
it's still open for discussion at the
moment
okay so this distance is 42 meters that
i've just traveled and that's going to
be the diameter of the mirror of the
extremely large telescope that's going
to be built
so just imagine this entire parking lot
pretty much filled with one mirror for a
giant telescope a telescope that will be
the biggest telescope on earth